Salut ! C'est la suite de la vidéo de vendredi.
Là il y a Leati qui est en train de se cacher parce que je vais faire une prédiction autour de la prédiction que m'avait fait Eli, vendredi.
Je vais faire une prédiction... Je vais faire ça...
ça...
et...
ça.
Voilà, ça c'est ma prédiction.
Dans quelques secondes vous allez ce que je vais faire à Leati et mon but c'est ça.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo de vendredi, évidemment regardez la avant.
Et si on est dans une Autolib c'est parce qu'on avait rendez-vous aux Buttes-Chaumont pour faire les deux vidéos, et il pleut à mort.
Il n'y a pas de bar à coté, donc on s'est trouvé ça en solution de repli. C'est un chouette studio.
Voici la suite de la vidéo. Je viens de passer à l'arrière de la voiture, c'est n'importe quoi en ce moment, avec Leati.
Salut Leati.
-Salut Fabi !
[rires]
Est-ce que t'es heureuse d'être dans une Autolib pour faire une vidéo avec moi ?
-Franchement plus improbable, tu meurs.
J'ai honte... Je suis désolé, j'ai honte de moi là.
En fait non, en vrai je n'ai pas honte.
J'ai donc préparé une prédiction au dos de la prédiction d'Eli.
C'est ici, de toute manière vous l'avez vu.
Toi tu ne l'as pas vu, on est d'accord.
-Non, je ne l'ai pas vu.
J'ai avec moi un jeu de carte ESP, composé de 25 cartes. Tu connais les cartes ESP ?
-Non.
Pour faire très rapide en fait, ce sont des symboles. Il y a 5 symboles différents qui sont représentés 5 fois:
Tu as des croix, des carrés, des cercles, des vagues et des étoiles.
C'était sur le travail du docteur Rhine, qui faisait un travail sur l'étude parapsychologique.
Et Zener en 1930 a décidé d'en faire des jeux de cartes comme cela, pour tester la sensibilité parapsychologique des gens.
Comme toi t'es empathique on devrait pouvoir faire des trucs avec ça.
On va essayer du moins...
-C'est dangereux là... [rires]
C'est très dangereux. Mais que ce passe-t-il ?!
Alors du coup il nous faudrait une table, mais comme nous n'avons pas de table, heureusement, on a des sièges.
-Et on a des petites jambes !
[rires]
Non, moi je suis très grand ! C'est pas vrai du tout !
Tu vas donner les cartes comme ça, et tu t'arrêtes quand tu veux, tu n'es pas obligé de donner tout le paquet.
Tu continues à les donner... Et quand tu en as marre tu arrêtes.
[distribution des cartes]
Ok. C'est terminé ?
-Oui.
Donc ça c'est ce qu'on n'utilisera pas, alors je les range.
On va faire une espèce de configuration, un espèce de petit triangle.
Ah ! On ne voit pas les cartes à la caméra !
Juste pour que vous sachiez, elle a donné autant de cartes qu'elle voulait et après elle a divisé à peu près en deux tas,
et les cartes qui restaient on les a mises de coté. Ça va je ne dis pas de bêtises ?
-Oui c'est bon.
Donc là à la caméra nous ne voyons que nos mains c'est ça ?
-Oui, et un peu les jambes.
D'accord, et les jambes, c'est formidable.
On va sélectionner 5 cartes, parce que j'ai mis 5 cartes sur ma prédiction. Et on va les positionner au fur et à mesure.
Tu me dis juste à chaque fois si tu veux qu'on prenne ce paquet là, ou si tu veux qu'on prenne ce paquet là.
-Celui-là.
Celui-là ? D'accord. Et on va faire ça 5 fois d'affilé.
A toi de choisir celui-là ou celui-ci.
-Celui-là.
On continue...
Celui-là ? Parce que j'ai ramené ma main vers là ?
-Non c'est... cherche pas.
[rires]
-Celui-là.
-Et celui-là.
Ce qui nous fait: un cercle, un deuxième cercle, une étoile, un carré, et une croix.
Tu vois, là ce sont les cartes qui restaient...
Des ronds, des ronds, des étoiles, des machins...
Donc tu as fait ça au hasard ? On est d'accord ?
-Oui.
On est pas complice ?
-Non ! [rires]
Si mais je ne le savais pas...!
-C'est ça ! J'ai peur !
La prédiction, vous l'avez vu, par contre toi tu ne l'as pas vu.
Sur la prédiction j'ai juste fait une petite configuration de cartes potentielles.
Avec une forme géométrique qui pouvait potentiellement donner un cercle, un cercle, une étoile, un carré et une croix !
C'est toi qu'on applaudi.
-Mais merde !
[rires]
-Mais c'est quoi ce truc de fou ?!
On a rond/rond; rond/rond, étoile/étoile, carré/carré et croix/croix.
-Mais non !
On va donc maintenant te bruler, puisque toute la Team Mentalo, te considère à présent comme une sorcière.
-Ils peuvent. Ils peuvent
Ca va ? Ca t'as plu ?!
-Oui, c'était génial, franchement !
Merci beaucoup d'être venue jusqu'ici pour tourner dans une Autolib et là on est en train de terminer les deux vidéos et
il commence à s'arrêter de pleuvoir. Tout à fait normal...
-C'est la poisse de ma vie !
En effet, c'est juste sa poisse. En plus avant qu'on monte dans l'Autolib j'avais dit a tous les coups c'est ce qu'il va se passer.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo, si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à nous laisser un généreux...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
-Même 2 ou 3 !
-Et 4 !
Ah non ! Un nombre impair, c'est très important ! Parce que sinon si tu en mets 2, ça l'annule...
-Alors il en faut 3 !
Voilà, trois c'est bien. 3, 5 ou 7...
Dans quelques jours je vous fait une annonce sur la chaine, sur ce qui va se passer cet été.
Dans quelques jours, c'est-à-dire jeudi. Jeudi, c'est aussi après-demain. Parce que je suis en train de penser en même temps que je vous parle.
Donc après-demain je vous fait une annonce sur ce qui va se passer cet été sur la chaine, n'hésitez pas à regarder ça, c'est très important.
J'ai aussi oublié de vous dire que Leati elle fait du cosplay, du super cosplay, elle a d'ailleurs de super photos sur Facebook
avec une armure, etc.
-C'est ça, avec mon armure. Qu'on peut retrouver sur la page "Onirium Studios"sur Facebook et vous allez tomber sur une super page qui fait des armures en cuir, etc.
Garçon ou fille, vous allez adorer, alors franchement allez-y, aimez et surtout commentez.
Si toi aussi tu veux t'habiller en cuir... va sur sa page ! Je la met directement le lien de la page dans le descriptif de la vidéo.
Comme ça tu me l'enverras et je le mettrai dans le descriptif, ce sera beaucoup plus simple.
Et j'ai vu ce qu'ils ont fait pour toi, c'est vraiment cool.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo, n'oubliez de vous abonner avant de partir.
Parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, depuis le premier janvier, donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !